im us bundesstaat arizona ist ein zug
auf einer brücke entgleist kurz danach
steht der gesamte güterzug in flammen
bislang soll es keine verletzten gegeben
haben und das ist ein kleines wunder
angesichts der bilder die wir ihnen
jetzt zeigen wollen
dicker rauch verdunkelt am mittwochabend
den himmel über tempe im us-bundesstaat
arizona ein güterzug ist auf einer
brücke entgleist und den brand geraten
teile der brücke stürzte daraufhin ein
wie ein sprecher der
eisenbahngesellschaft union pacific
sagte sei von der zug besatzung niemand
verletzt worden es gebe jedoch berichte
über eine rauchvergiftung
der zug hatte holz geladen aber auch
einige tankwagen dabei über lecks gab es
zunächst keine berichte
etwa 90 feuerwehrleute waren im einsatz
der see über den die brücke führt ist
ein beliebtes erholungsgebiet